[Music]
whoa whoa that was loud
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith hi I'm Luc Renard Hey
we are here live in front of a studio
audience is that that's how they used to
say it game shows in front of a bar in
front of a bar audience at the scum and
villainy Cantina here on Hollywood
Boulevard in Hollywood California put
your hands together so the folks at home
know your real
[Applause]
after copious amounts of bitching on
Twitter over the course of the last two
weeks when we get into the question and
answer period at the end of the show a
mic will be handed out there were so
many people so many people complain that
that like I can't hear the [ __ ]
questions I could barely hear Bernard
Anne cuz he won't speak into the [ __ ]
mic I can't hear that I can't hear the
[ __ ] questions like you gotta at
least repeat him so we'll be JC we'll be
running around the microphone like we
would give his people paper cuts is that
much [ __ ] drum is terrible imma be up
here like swallowing issue alright the
mouth Oh last night this is the show is
called fat man on Batman ladies and
gentlemen Batman being a part of the
Justice League last night was the
Hollywood premiere of the Justice League
movie it was and we can't tell you [ __ ]
about it because we were not invited
[Laughter]
no juice whatsoever I had Athena finger
the granddaughter of Bill Finger the
co-creator finally recognized co-creator
of Batman the character of Batman Athena
came over to my house yesterday we
recorded of audio episode of fat man on
Batman bless you
at the end of it she's like I'm going to
see Justice League down the street bless
you as well something's going around
Justice League had a premiere right at
the what used to be the Kodak Theatre
but Kodak you know nobody makes film
anymore so now it's the Dolby Theatre I
think yeah right at the Dolby theater to
have the premiere literally I could like
if I if I dragged ass I'd be there in
ten minutes from where I live like
that's how close it is I could [ __ ]
throw a tissue and hit Jason Momoa in
the [ __ ] hair she goes are you going
and I was like no no I don't I don't
know anybody
I mean I have no juice I don't know what
to tell you like it's crazy we don't get
to go until when tomorrow which is like
one day earlier than everybody else
pretty much we literally it pays nothing
to have a show with the title Batman in
the title man
it is the piteous of pity [ __ ]
screenings basically really is it's like
minutes before anything else everybody
else is like just a little like we just
got online early and they had mercy on
us
I gotta think man honestly but I'm on
some sort of Affleck cease-and-desist
list you know like when they're like hey
man who's your guest list he's like
anybody but [ __ ] the guy that made
Mallrats
he's still [ __ ] talking about me I'm
ins appeal to most Morgan home dears so
I may be it has something to do with
that maybe they just forgot my imitation
or maybe I saw I remember I saw Batman V
Superman early and I said some some
honest [ __ ] about it I also I also blew
it up I gave it a [ __ ] pretty solid
review but I also said some real [ __ ]
about it and maybe that they were maybe
I'm on Zack Snyder [ __ ] list
or maybe you're on the you're standing
miss to me [ __ ] list because I've been
talking [ __ ] about these movies for a
good long while it's true you're what's
holding us back the worst part of this
I'm the one that's always like there's
hope and your looks [ __ ] hopeless
I'm the yoke on your back man I'm sorry
I look forward to seeing this Justice
League movie I'll even pay for it if I
got in [ __ ] you don't know cuz we're
going tomorrow for free oh really I
still
pay for it out here because I know I'll
go see it again in the theater cuz I
know I'm gonna be like what through most
of it and I'm also gonna be trying to
figure out who did what you know what
I'm saying first one I'm just gonna let
it wash all over me like a holy [ __ ]
justice league is finally happening and
then the second one is gonna be like re
let me look at Superman's mustache yeah
I'll grab the seams looking for the joss
whedon zack snyder scenes yeah that'll
be the fun way to watch it and then go
see the third time with Jay just because
he loves all of those movies and doesn't
critique them at all you know he's the
one through whom I found joy in Batman V
Superman the most joyless movie ever
made
sitting next to him and then suddenly
the [ __ ] parademons show up we both
look at each other and said parademons
and suddenly i enjoyed the movie so much
more when i saw it with him so he's a
good guy to watch the flick with I'll
watch it once with if you need me to
hold your hand while something awesome
happens and we could just say it
together that's true yeah so amazing
Steppenwolf yeah that's I don't think
anybody's ever gonna [ __ ] say that do
you think there's I know I see the
premiere happened though and let's talk
about the reaction I saw on Twitter was
very positive it kind of was yeah
there's I heard people say if you expect
this to be a Marvel movie don't do that
but if you take it on its own merits
then there's joy to be had as you just
heard we lost 75 percent of the audience
just there's lots of little Eggen it's
not a Marvel movie what's the [ __ ]
point
they're doing it right don't do it wrong
well yeah like everybody seems to love
Azra Miller's flash and sort of like now
they're excited for what about Mammoet
of people like his Aquaman they kind of
at this point I just want to see the
rest of Atlantis like what the [ __ ] does
it sound like if everybody sounds like
that it's like a surfer village of
[ __ ] steroid it out bro honks
underwater that's true what would what
would Black Manta sound like
why that's a bigot oh it's awesome
I would have went with flava flav that
would offend the better voice for Black
Manta if you're going extreme pick a
voice go ahead
Black Manta I'm the hype tip okay so
neither of us seen the movie but the
reaction on Twitter thus far has been
positive I honestly and see I mean
granted it's a premiere so most people
going are some way involved with the
movie but I saw some people who didn't
have any skin in the game who we're
going like it's [ __ ] it's good enough
yes
I didn't see any raves yet but like I'm
not looking that hard at this point all
we want is good enough yeah that's very
so but one thing that I saw in some
tweets and that's when I jumped out of
the Justice League ashtag thread was
something happens they said stay to the
end and then there are a few other
people said something about the ending
did you see that do you know what it is
everybody's mom's name is Martha
[Applause]
that's DC's IP of a PS seen for like are
we doing it right are we doing a Marvel
style how do we stitch these guys
together [ __ ] ruin the PS ending
never do it again what is it do you know
I don't know I don't know can't take a
guess sure shoot [ __ ] shot in the
dark okay didn't read any reviews don't
know anything clearly can't get my fat
ass invited to the premiere so I have no
inside information my gas green lantern
appearance a lantern shows up whoo
nobody saw it did you see it you saw the
movie
go ahead did you see the movie you saw
the movie all right so you shut up
it wasn't care inside [ __ ] your insides
we're going outside
JC get a microphone over there fast you
have seen the movie okay so let's just
first we don't want to spoil [ __ ] for
everybody you sign an NDA was I well
that means you can't say anything but
you can nod all right so I'm watching
you there lit up cat ears and I'll see
you nodding in the darkness was oh wow
was I was I right you're wrong no Green
Lantern does not show up what else can
we ask yes or no is the movie good I
think so yes that's more than nodding
your [ __ ] head man how is it two
hours only two hours 11 minutes all
right with credits and [ __ ] like that
well no I think that was like it's
almost exactly decided we're brothers
you guys don't see it NDA all right well
wait here's a big question and this is a
spoiler question is Steppenwolf the only
villain who shows up why
[Music]
they're saying don't spoil it all you
have to do is nod yes or no is
Steppenwolf the only villainy yes ed no
does he have an evil puppet that was
where I went where'd you go I was trying
to figure out why her knobs don't have
head movements and she just said [ __ ]
well yes and no nod is put your head in
a circle it's like no noncommittal did
you uh would you guys sign something yes
how did you see it
are you industry no we got advance
screening through one of the agencies
that fills theaters with people like
that aren't in the industry so if they
couldn't find enough people to go see a
free screening of Justice League they
had to recruit so you're normies then
you're not you're not in the industry
what the [ __ ] are you worried about the
NDA for you think they're really gonna
come and take your home fair enough man
but don't be afraid of Warner Brothers
it's not both of them just the one you
got to watch out for dot that's the one
you gotta [ __ ] watch out for there's
a good brother a bad brother
yeah absolutely a war there like Loki
and Thor this is a good movie what about
a new to sob as well you guys is on
board right now what about you in the
middle did you see it or no you weren't
there now would you pay for it and I
mean yourself a free yeah now that
you've seen a more Wonder Woman there
was closer Wonder Woman what the [ __ ]
are you people scared of man nope
nobody's leaving isn't our deal come
here put the hurt on you guys
fair enough you guys PlayStation 1
graphics for part of it you know like
when they were not finished yet are you
being critical now now you're gonna get
[ __ ] sued why if you like it that's
great you like the movie yes will you
pay to see a you're going again that's
you to see it where I want to see it
where instead of graphic goes special
effect goes here in words oh you saw it
like three months aw early cut of this
[ __ ] oh so you haven't even seen the
final four all you know I could be right
about the Green Lantern yeah Steppenwolf
didn't have texture yet some of the
video graphs did yeah yeah it's like
sounds like Priebe is more than anything
alright and that's coming off of
unfinished version of me right on
alright let's jump back to the inside
man yeah what do you know you had
somebody inside
give him a hold on hold on Mike to get
to you one of the first things I asked
was would you pay a ticket for it and
immediately I got absolutely absolutely
I paid money to go see this movie on my
own yeah see for free and even said I
mean my wife's not really into it but
I'd go pay tickets to go see this movie
again he would drag his wife yep yep
that's what I get at a story he's like I
like it so much my wife's gonna suffer
through it you know you get a lot of
what worked and Wonder Woman you get you
just get more of that obviously the he
doesn't know that he's the comedic
relief basically so I'm not gonna say
it's similar to another movie about
defenders of the universe so wait is so
using using the Avengers scale he's Thor
right no he's more tracks Oh so using
the Guardian scale he and Rick what yeah
so yeah the Aquaman comes off more but
in a good way like this is a movie that
they finally go okay maybe we should
start doing things that people love
that's that's not job one how do we what
should we do - people don't like I got
an idea let's make it entertaining
damn it Stuart shut up you don't get to
talk anymore the DC Universe the Marvel
you know the Marvel way alright thank
you for that man that's good to know man
we got some insight into the do you know
what I was doing last night instead of
going to the Justice League premiere
that I wasn't invited to so it wasn't an
option anyway tell me I watched the
first two episodes of The Punisher but
I'm so good I didn't want to [ __ ]
spit it out
Wow what the [ __ ] I mean I have I have
Punisher juice not Justice League juice
Wow man it says what they gave me - they
gave me six and I'm slowly making my way
through 613 I think Jesus that one's 13
episodes all 13 and not the defenders
that was only six and it felt like long
at six was it just it wasn't sex right
eight you just missed two but it did
feel even long at that at eight why why
do they insist on that [ __ ] 13 number
I have no idea
there must be financially some cerebrese
international sales or whatever business
bullsh let him off the hook do 10 and
even that feels like a stretch sometimes
but anyway [ __ ] that editor and the his
nation Netflix and Marvel Studios should
take the advice of the guy that made
tusk back to you
what did you think of the first two
episodes I thought as badass as the
[ __ ] trailer
well nothing could be quite that badass
at a sustained level but there's a it's
it's interesting because so much these
first two episodes are about character
it's about reminding us who Frank Castle
is and and using his kind of PTSD to
give us the flashbacks to the life that
he had beforehand like we don't need an
origin story of Frank Castle at this
point well did we get one in daredevil
season 2 no not quite but I mean if
you're watching The Punisher you know
pretty much what you're getting into
right but using him unable to sleep
using him as somebody haunted by his
Bell flashback so much of this show is
about loss it's about tangible almost
physical loss and so to be able to see
that register on him and the life that
he's tried to lead after you know
whatever happened in daredevil after
getting revenge for what happened to his
family like all of us of is dispensed
with and that was just a man like in
search of what life means and punching
and snapping knees use a hammer at one
point it's kind of badass a little bit
like Thor but snap what if Thor snapped
patellas what's a patella you kneecap a
kneecap
why don't you say that I did [ __ ]
fancy boy leaving 75 years I was out I
know a word good freedom so he takes in
the Hammers of his [ __ ] Rex this
group of it's kind of Awesome you've
only seen two episodes but what does the
plot seem to be who's the bad guy so far
we haven't gotten to bad guy yet so
either got 13 episodes 13 episodes we
it's not even see thomas Howell seemed
to have been the beginning of the bad
guy and then Mike Rowe it's very much
about introducing Mike Rowe into his
world news life which is kind of great
yeah then micro vs. I'm used to the
chubby micro yeah so far no van so you
know maybe he'll grow that's where it
gains weight yeah the ride it was one
[ __ ] rep positive representation for
fat people in comics I remember that
like read mad as a kid being like
could be him couldn't be the Punisher
would never show the Stars
giant skull would spread so wide across
my chest but I couldn't be the guy in
the chair yeah but it's done really well
is microchip the original guy in the
chair you think no yeah anybody else who
microchip predates Oracle from the
Batman universe crippled Barbara Gordon
Oracle I mean yeah I think the microchip
goes before her professor X is the first
guy in a wheelchair yeah he's the one
who's like he's the only information you
need my x-men to me my x-men it's true
his [ __ ] to my x-men fetch me a bagel my
x-men [ __ ] what version did you read
that must be in the middle of the
Clairemont run where he must really used
to talk about he's like maybe you can
have him get bagels I don't know any we
just got out of fetish club so I'm a
little hungry so he was a guy in a chair
but not the guy in the chair as we think
of the guy in the chair who is it a very
assistant role helping the hero yeah in
spider-man suit it's the voice in the
head just like Iron Man's suit he's got
used to have Jarvis now is Friday what
was the name of Karen
spider-man's AI I think there's also
Theo from die hard is an original guy in
a chair computer hacker dude he's just
making [ __ ] the quarterback is toast
that one that's a bad guy man the chair
usually helps the good guy well Hans
Gruber's a hero of his own story holy
[ __ ] I'm like I wanna
next time you're over the house yeah and
I'm smoking say that again that will be
a deep [ __ ] diet you can literally
swim through that entire movie backwards
and just be like he's just a man bucking
the system well there's there's this old
story I remember I interviewed Steven
D'Souza the screenwriter diehard about
we were doing some story about movie
quotes and 100 greatest movie quotes of
all time mmm he told me that they put
the scene in die hard where he kills
Takagi so brutally brutally at the
conference room table yes I'm going to
count to three there will not be a fall
they put that scene in because audiences
are bad Alan Rickman thank you it's
better than my Flavor Flav apparently
but they put that scene in because
audiences liked Hans Gruber too much
they needed him to be brutal they needed
him to kill somebody violently and
publicly otherwise the audiences were
rooting for him well charismatic and
magnetic [ __ ] yeah you want to take a
corporation over this [ __ ] down and
at the end of the day like as you meet
him he's like a corporate raider you
know going after the head of a company
and you don't find out he's a thief he's
an exceptional thief but you find that
out at the end so at that point when he
shoots the guy yeah they got to put some
stakes out because otherwise you're
sitting there watching the movie goes
all white-collar crime [ __ ] them all
until some blood is shed in the knee
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] serious and then a lot
of people get killed the late 80s when
xenophobia was just high enough like
Japan is buying real estate in America
they're going to invade buy real estate
and business and they're killing us with
a microchip and oh my god that didn't
happen yeah
but uh but there was there was a deep
sort of like anti-japanese business
strain in sort of pop culture in America
at the time was there yeah like you ever
see Rising Sun yeah with Sean Connery Oh
Stevie people saw it yeah with Sean
Connery like it's all about like the
sort of xenophobia against Japanese
business interests and and sort of fear
for them having diplomatic immunity and
all that [ __ ] but that was a thing
in sort of like the late 80s hmm and so
to have a bad guy ripping off a Japanese
company in such high style he was the
hero for a stretch until he had to do
something awful and then when he killed
somebody everyone's go he's the best
okay he's the one yes not Robin Hood
he's just a [ __ ] murderer yeah an
exceptional murderer how do you know
this
Steven D'Souza the screenwriters and
when he said they put the scene in they
didn't go back and reshoot no it was mid
production I think that they couple
people cuz there that was a script that
was written along the way yes I saw
somebody today said that it was
originally supposed to be a commando
sequel which my first command or Die
commando because the die hard script
wasn't originally die hard it was
something else it was a book right sixty
seconds or something seconds it was good
and then die hard to was originally a
different movie that they then turned
into a die hard movie as was die hard
three was a spec action script called
Simon Says right which they then Reapers
yeah repurposed die hard three and they
kept using the Simon Says drag I mean
the the die hard book that it was based
on had been around for long enough the
Frank Sinatra was supposed to play John
McClane at one are you [ __ ] me yeah
yeah it was gonna be a Sinatra jammy-jam
the one in the detective his name of the
movie that's the name of the book the
name is detective that's based on the
same book that die hards based on why am
I the host of this show
any of this and I'm a [ __ ] huge
diehard fan well it's not that man on
diehard I think you're you're okay good
point
despite us spending half an hour talking
about the inner workings of diehard at
the top of the show all right man so
wait we talked about Justice League
talked about Punisher so let and you've
only seen two I've seen two but I like
the two that I've seen do you see any
names directing it that you were like oh
not that I noticed
okay not that stood out anything stand
out other than a hammer and some [ __ ]
kneecap
well I'm sorry his patella he's patella
Fusco no I mean it's it's a lot of
performance is really good Karen page
shows up because we always knew she
would yeah why it looks like they get in
a relationship of some sort I haven't
gotten that far but she he needs her for
information she's supposed to wind up
with Matt Murdock that's what everybody
well as a daredevil fan she's taking the
long road
yeah lots of grunting on Jon Bernthal
spark and he grunts very well you can't
protect Rick and then for daredevil you
think you can't protect to read you
don't know what love is read you got a
hold on tight read I remember like you
know we're so deep in the walking dead
you don't really think about season one
but it was such a [ __ ] up concept that
[ __ ] Andrew was Andrew Lincoln he
wakes up and he's like I'm gonna find my
family and his wife is [ __ ] his best
friend and they're like oh [ __ ] what do
we do and it's like [ __ ] that the
apocalypse but like I remember Jason
Mewes was fixated on that like I was
like how do you like The Walking Dead
he's like it's [ __ ] up that she [ __ ]
his friend
and I'm like that's what you got out of
that [ __ ] show he's like yeah man if
I go disappearing during the apocalypse
don't please don't [ __ ] my wife
and I was like I won't I doubt you wanna
[ __ ] me he's like you don't know in a
zombie world he's making an argument for
the different choices one would have to
make under duress weird concept anyway
alright so we're done with the news
we're done with that part of the news
let's die but if it means definitely got
scheduled I know you pulled news you
went out of your way this news I told
you I went to work I'd earned my [ __ ]
keep good bottle of waters paid for by
news Sony is making a hold on Morbius
the living vampire movie are you
[ __ ] me four reasons why not like
look you know they don't want to go
[ __ ] around with their spider-man
stuff because they want Marvel to kind
of be involved in that but you know they
can't sit around and not make [ __ ]
spider-man movies unless Marvel's
involved so this is a way where they
could be like look we'll take a [ __ ]
lower tier spider universe character and
do a whole movie on because one day then
we can have a meet spider-man or maybe
spider-man pops in on this movie but
Morbius the living vampire is a [ __ ]
cool character it's a cool character
very 70s very [ __ ] badass
I don't want any spider-man movies that
Kevin Feige hasn't signed off on I don't
want any spite him in the universe
movies yet and sign off we almost got a
gun [ __ ] like sinister six movie I would
have taken it I didn't give a [ __ ] I
liked that last version of the Rhino
with [ __ ] Paul Giamatti I thought it
looked cool everyone else in the rooms
like this looks stupid I was like if
you're gonna do the Rhino that [ __ ]
looks plausible a dude in a rhino suits
gonna look ridiculous but we will we
will get that eventually no bill will be
some way to do that yes so they're
making that movie that you're excited
about but whatever I am I think that's I
think that's a good idea
you get into all the [ __ ] characters
and horror movie characters that hard
titles that Marvel used to do you could
do werewolf by night you could do
[ __ ] Dracula they had Drac
version of Dracula son of Dracula you
could do you get into the [ __ ]
satanic stuff what's the name of what
was the Satanic book that Marvel did
hellström didn't it I mean that was I'm
talking in the 70s when Satanism was at
its peak Marvel Marvel dreamed low when
the devil like The Exorcist around the
period the Exorcist when like the devil
was very marketable Marvel was like why
don't we have Stan Lee himself was like
we need a Satan book and they have a
title called son of Satan which is
literally like my dad's the devil but I
couldn't fight him but it's like he's
born of how is that damian hellström I
wasn't that the character that's his
name yeah I just know mr. son estate
that's all I didn't read the book too
frightening for me in the 70s it in case
this adds to your confidence level the
two dudes who wrote it
this new Boreas movie also Morbius movie
yes Morbius the gods they did the last
witch hunter with the thing Ving Rhames
would be enough thousand percent better
if thing Rangers in that movie Vin
Diesel's witch hunter movie that that
was the movie made because he's a big
fan of Dungeons and Dragons yes okay and
gods of Egypt which is maybe the worst
movie of like the last five years again
and then I make any comment those dudes
who you mentioned listen this podcast go
yeah and he made [ __ ] yoga hose or so
[ __ ] him in the ass I I can't [ __ ]
come down them because they wrote those
scripts hey I haven't seen either of
those movies and B what if like their
next script is [ __ ] genius and this
is the next script it could be but I can
say cuz I've seen both of those movies
and I did not make anything that
whatever you talk about holy [ __ ] these
guys get the job I'm sure everybody can
change maybe they got way better at
their jobs
so I don't know I'm all for the idea
Morbius is a good idea and it also I
feel allows them to do something without
gone keV is this okay I'm sure given
baggies like I'm busy with the [ __ ]
Marvel Universe you want to make a
Morbius movie go [ __ ] yourselves that's
fine just don't ruin what I'm doing I'll
tell you why I want there to be a blade
TV series really badly yes and I feel
like the more you start to strip-mine
the sort of supernatural Marvel stuff
like there's no reason why Morbius the
living vampire would not be in a [ __ ]
Blade TV show and if he's belongs to I
just don't want it but he doesn't belong
to the Blade TV show Morbius the living
vampire as part of the spider-man
University of spider-man villain so he's
goes with part-and-parcel the Sony
anyway so you can sit there and [ __ ]
pipe dream about Morbius being in Blade
all you want but it's just not gonna
happen don't ruin it for the rest of us
that want a Morbius [ __ ] movie it's
our first fight ladies and a chill fell
across the body
I'm all for it yeah it's just
implausible you're talking about I like
the idea of a blade TV show that's great
but you know [ __ ] it's not gonna have
Marvel characters that don't belong to
the blade universe in that we know it
fair enough especially now everyone's so
tight about the IP and they're getting
spread out across a bunch of different
networks now it's not even just like
Netflix has every Marvel thing where's
that [ __ ] the mutants show Fox what
do you mean not for long oh right
there's a rumor about Disney buying Fox
all right the way you said not for long
and the way the news cycle works I
thought something had happened before we
jumped up on Mike's know we could talk
about that well we talked about it on
the last show but it wasn't here there
was a rumor going around that Fox had
its tires kicked by Disney to buy
everything that's not the news division
right 21st Century Fox everything a news
and and sports they're keeping sports as
well news and sport
you're so not on my radar didn't even
think about it but you're right a lot of
people make money off sports as well so
news and sports that's what Fox wants to
be in right they're done with their
movie history which i think is a little
sad that's how the company began Darryl
zanuck I believe started [ __ ] twice
and searchlights long before there was
ever thought of hey let's do a news
division cable news let's own sports or
a Sports Network
it was movies but they're done with it
they're you know like who knows like
it's it's kicking the tires no papers
have been signed absolutely true I'm
sure at some point the government will
step in and be like [ __ ] you we can't
have this giant goddamn company know why
though they're not they're not joining
they're just having a garage sale and
Disney just picking it's entertainment
bones clean I don't see that as the
joining of or the fusing of two
different companies what would that be a
merger a merger in corporate speak feels
more like Disney going in and being like
oh you know I'll take a little from
column a Kombi it's Chinese food menu
right there man like you just go in and
take what you want Walter but if you
take enough then you fill a truck and
that's when it gets problematic when
there's one movie studio that controls
that much IP that has that much market
share that has that much dominance in
the marketplace that drives down
competition as opposed to elevating it
but they're not putting but Fox wants to
go out of business it's not like
Disney's putting them out of business
now it'll just mean the government will
look at it and say I'm sorry it's too
much which they can do its antitrust but
then what happens that point Fox is like
now we're stuck owning a movie division
and a TV division that the whole world
knows we don't give a [ __ ] about I've
just tried to sell the Disney
unsuccessfully by the way enjoy your
next 20th Century Fox Christmas release
you know like it would have to I just
don't see why like yeah I think they
would rather the government rather they
sold to private investors or private
equity of private money or Elon Musk
more than they would rather [ __ ]
Disney swallow another giant company but
that would just create a new Studios
which they're fine with they'd be fine
with there being a new studio as opposed
to there being less studios
I hope you're right it sounded so
serious I hope your eyes like [ __ ] it
we're talking about career or something
like that like I hear they're not gonna
bomb us I'm like I hope you're right
yeah [ __ ] talking about whether or
not the [ __ ] x-men will go to Disney
awesome
god no you're right Jimmy Stone and
lastly as important to me as the idea of
like North Korea could drop a bomb in
any minute I'm like yeah but if the
x-men and the Avengers were in the same
[ __ ] movie that would crack the
mantle of the earth well it just it
gives us more reasons to stay alive true
like I'm just edging it on I Center
[ __ ] black panthers like February
just don't blow us up about February
all right [ __ ] x-men Avengers what
that's like five years away we need five
more years oh my god I figured that if
they were like look man if you could
just make it that long we will give you
[ __ ] the entire Marvel Universe verse
each other all of our characters all of
our IP comes back a good version of
fantastic for everything you [ __ ]
always wished for in one giant [ __ ]
mondo crossover movie five parter 90
minutes a pop comes out every other
month for a year [ __ ] strength
[Laughter]
in the incredible show up in their cuz
they [ __ ] can and there's Jack Sparrow
coos he gives a [ __ ] and [ __ ] stars
and [ __ ] then we will let Darth Vader
whip out his lightsaber and [ __ ] take
on Magneto
who the [ __ ] would win Doctor Doom wins
that ladies and gentlemen this is the
amazing movie like for this somebody has
to go stop North Korea I was like I will
blow that man in North Korea until there
is peace just to get to that movie
Disney I'm your man the hero this city
meets yes not the one who wants that
dudes gonna filleted King John for a
long time widow's champ I hope that puts
behind a North Korean watchlist now he
said he would blow the supreme leader
look why is that a bad thing all right
what else we got there is there's going
to be a lower the rings TV show yes now
I heard this last week that there was
going to be a Lord of the Rings TV show
and they didn't say if it was going to
be connected to the new on movies now
they have since announced that yes it is
in continuity with the new line movies
the all 48 of them but it is a prequel
series that happens before the
Fellowship of the Ring so it's just
hobbits hanging out it's it's unclear if
it's after the Hobbit and before the
Fellowship or if it's before the events
of The Hobbit of it this summer ilium or
whatever all I know is they're spending
so much [ __ ] money on this show who's
making it Amazon so they're desperate
for their own Game of Thrones they want
to give him a pen they're like everybody
loves Lord of the Rings I know nobody
saw those movies I don't know I feel
like like and maybe I'm wrong they just
were not like I you know I respect the
[ __ ] out of it but I was not a
like oh my god this is my religion and I
respect other people that are like it is
my religion ship but if it was your
religion like have you had enough at
this point or are you like I'll watch
more I mean yeah I already gave me 15
hours worth of walking through
middle-earth I mean the beauty of Game
of Thrones is it was new like every
aspect of it was new to those of us that
didn't read the books and the fun of it
for those that did read the books is
like holy [ __ ] I can't believe they
chose this one man dragons and dicks
that's what I call this and they decide
to make this a show [ __ ] yeah HBO
so I can understand like falling in love
with that but this is like hey man
remember those movies you loved and
watched and [ __ ] for hours and hours and
hours this had happened you didn't see
with none of the people you love I
remember one night when the Hobbit was
first announced that it was gonna be two
movies in there three movies I was like
hey listen Peter Jackson makes pizza
right he told me I was gonna get two
pizzas and now I'm gonna get three
pizzas how is that bad and then I saw
the third pizza that much pizza one
pizza would have been awesome it should
come in one box so I'm good with the
pizza I don't but there's a generation
as better than the prequel pizzas though
better than the period open up that box
you know like that don't even look like
pizza is that what you think like pizza
looks like how the [ __ ] do you do those
other pizzas take this back Jar Jar well
I suppose there will be a generation of
kids for whom this will be their first
lord of the rings and I don't [ __ ]
like you kids watch Amazon Prime yeah I
look I'm 47 I still don't know how to
find it Netflix is real easy but you
know whenever I click on the Amazon app
I wind up shop and buy more dog food and
I never get to watch but I wanna watch a
Willie Nelson record I wanted to watch
it it's like I want to watch this thing
I've heard about man that I'm like wait
a second [ __ ] I don't have enough dog
chews and then I started buying him and
then my wife's like why don't you just
go [ __ ] down to pet coats right down
the street and I'm like cuz I was trying
to watch [ __ ] transgender transparent
[Applause]
old man streaming yes
so apparently children may or may not
watch Amazon if they could find it they
probably can cuz I really think kids are
the driving for like kids aren't the
driving force of Game of Thrones and
that's everybody wants to be Game of
Thrones they all want their Game of
Thrones they'll wonder Game of Thrones
but it's not like you know my god
[ __ ] preschoolers love Game of
Thrones like they would if they could
watch it totally maybe not a little
frightening a lot of blood a bit but you
know lower the range those books are
among the most popular books in the
world and they are intergenerational and
they cross all kinds of demographic
lines and it makes sense that if you're
looking for something that you hope will
appeal to a lot of people to choose the
thing that already appeals to a lot of
people right that said they spent two
hundred fifty million dollars just
getting the right to make a show what
that's what the rights cost a quarter of
a billion dollar order of a billion Tony
Bezos to the choke unist a yeah the
token estate who now he's long gone
did he has children he did so his sons
still around living [ __ ] man like he's
quarter of a billion dollars he's like
are you [ __ ] me they already made it
go ahead
[ __ ] do it again oh my god one more
round one more round put them on the
glass yeah so 250 million dollars to get
the rights to make this show and they
anticipated costing probably between
another hundred and hundred and fifty
million dollars for the first season of
the show so it cost more to make the
show than to make the show cost more to
get the rights to make the show than it
a season of the show Wow and they've
already committed to multiple seasons
this shows already so expensive I gotta
watch it that's what they're hoping for
that's the idea that's the idea Patton
Oswalt you said this joke where it was
like if you could make a movie that cost
100 million dollars you could just show
me a hundred million dollars and I would
pay $10 to look at that 100 million
dollars like it's this expensive I gotta
see what you spent four hundred million
dollars on that shows up on my TV that's
wow you're right that would be huge
your television show and imagine just
like a bunch of dudes a bar just [ __ ]
short people drinking in a bar yeah
right
the Prancing Pony for like [ __ ] five
episodes if they hire me to direct an
episode that's all
hobbits talking to each other about
remember that time we all want walking
let's not do that [ __ ] again
oh [ __ ] we're down for zonas thank God
for the Eagles right can I get some
shoes up in this mug cuz this hurts yeah
well if your Amazon you got all the
money in the world so more of a say Liam
yeah now the quickest been said Allah
a quarter of a billion though I guess
there aren't many other places that
could afford them no I mean Netflix
maybe if they wanted it but Amazon just
what does Netflix app now that house of
cards is going to be taken out of
commission what's their big claim to
fame
stranger things oh that's [ __ ] huge
right yeah is that the biggest thing
they've ever had it is the big it is the
biggest single thing they've ever had
but the Marvel stuff have done
incredibly well for them that's right
they got a Marvel franchise and stuff
like that from now so is that their Game
of Thrones the Marvel I think shows I
think so at this point what Hulu doesn't
have their Game of Thrones hulu has
Handmaid's Tale which won them in Emmys
but is kind of their Game of Thrones
they will have a little thing I like to
call Castle Rock next year that's right
you're having heart that is the next
game of it [ __ ] better be this I
would like to keep working please mmm be
a big [ __ ] hit Thank You mask you
this tell me as I eat the frankenburg
if that show took off yes and they were
like we need you writing on this show
all the [ __ ] time mm-hmm like your
episode was everything and we want to
[ __ ] him do a whole season based your
showrunner that's how much they liked
your episode yeah do you still do this
show I mean there will be like a bunch
of skyping in shows when I'm on set in
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
Massachusetts like hey bar guys [ __ ]
cold out here but I knew it you're
already high road nuts and [ __ ] like
that
I got a history of hanging out with
people and they get popular and
successful and then I never hear from
the beginning so I just want to make
sure that hearing for the long yeah I
live to buck trends my friends there you
go don't be an athlet mean this the
premier was down the street from my
house and he knows this cuz it was his
house once I have a show called fat man
never mind what's next on the news do
you remember when what did I say back no
one Universal was on like hey we got a
we got our own universe we're Conor the
dark universe and we're gonna have a
bunch of these movies in it and the
mummy in the Bride of Frankenstein and
the Invisible Man and I was very excited
about the birth of the dark universe and
can't wait to see it grow don't give me
any bad news about it don't want to hear
it
all right next news item oh [ __ ] are
they calling it quits already the
offices on the universal lot these big
[ __ ] swanky offices they built for
dark universe are now empty oh my god
well I mean nobody's in there because
everybody left because they're never
making these movies and they've now all
but admitted it so wait what came first
the studio's like we're never gonna do
this [ __ ] again and then people are like
well I guess I'll leave now or were
people like I bet they're never gonna do
this [ __ ] again let's leave and
Universal is like huge
it's once they pulled Bride of
Frankenstein off the release schedule
the writing was kind of on the wall that
bill condoms never make in that movie
that are never moving on to the
Invisible Man they're never moving on to
the Creature from the Black Lagoon that
they probably wanted to do why that and
that's like the easiest like it's
[ __ ] no-brainer at this point it's
all CG and [ __ ] like that yeah I mean
they made me mom and these are easy
[ __ ] concepts like how do you [ __ ] up
the mummy like Brendan Fraser did it
right a thousand times they get one
[ __ ] swipe at the [ __ ] Apple and
they got Tom Cruise as their [ __ ] bat
and [ __ ] like that not just the money
that was the problem what was it
he wasn't the money yeah spoilers sorry
in case you were gonna go do that that
would have been amazing campaign Tommy
Mummy Mummy can you hear me
mummy [ __ ] yeah they're not making any
more of those movies so how many we get
one would we official logo yeah we
technically got two because Dracula
untold was theoretically technically
part of that right and even that didn't
work out for them as well as they hoped
no and so you got the mummy which like
did okay internationally but definitely
not what they spent on it and it turns
out that you need to make a good movie
before you make a universe and
you'd think they would remember that but
no did Marva marvel of course is thought
of as the first studio to make a
universe and stuff did they didn't say
that out the gate right they just I mean
we started putting those tags at the end
and people were like ooh yeah let me the
the Avengers initiative thing was
literally I think like a last minute add
that the movies good we like it with its
tracking really well and people seem to
respond should we do another one of
these yeah probably
how do we [ __ ] it we'll have Sam Jackson
show up that'll be great and that's the
backdoor birth of the universe which
sounds way [ __ ] sexier than I meant
it but that's it wasn't pre-planned and
pre-programmed where the dark universe
is like here's the t-shirts here's the
official mugs we're ready to [ __ ] go
the mummies gonna be huge what everyone
run anytime you see somebody open up
like a desktop and just start looking at
logos on it you know that there's a
problem right ooh somebody got that I
remember that all right so yeah no more
that rests in peace dark universe we
hardly knew you yeah I mean there it's a
shame that was a good name for a
universe - now it's gone it was there
talking about other producers maybe
coming in to take it over like Jason
Blum is a name that's been mentioned
that's smart
that makes absolute sense I'll do one if
they want me to do creature to the Black
Lagoon and I'd do that in a [ __ ]
heartbeat that'd be amazing I wouldn't
know what the story would be but like
I'll tell you this much The Creature
from the Black Lagoon from the guy who
made tusks at the budget of tusk I'd see
that [ __ ] movie
oh yeah then again I saw tusks too and I
was alone when I saw it so thank you
alright so moving on from the dark
universe uh oh man like really would you
I wouldn't give up that easily I'd be
like [ __ ] it let's keep going let's
refigure this out like it's crazy yeah I
think the problem was of the the
producers that they had overseeing it
have both sort of like [ __ ] you we don't
want it Chris Morgan who was the fast
and furious guy yeah he's back in Fast
and Furious Land he's like look I'd
rather make successful movies yeah have
you seen the billions of dollars we make
with these guys I'd rather work with
cars [ __ ] this
and Alex Kurtzman was the other guy and
he's off helming the Star Trek universe
for CBS all access oh he works on that
show yeah but that's his show oh it's
like that's working like they people
like that allegedly Wow
well thank anybody still watching Star
Trek discovery no yes yes does anybody
like Star Trek discovery let's do they
don't know let's do the other does
anyone watch the Orval that's Star Trek
on TV that's the quote they want all
right so what do we got next
we got Wentworth Miller who was Captain
Cold Captain Cold
one of the most interesting performances
on TV in the last ten years
like really I don't give a [ __ ] who you
are man that's that was a brilliant
choice the way he played that character
was [ __ ] interesting and fascinating
I don't know I've never seen him in
anything else Jason Mewes is a big fan
of Prison Break I think he's on there I
don't know if he does the same kind of
delivery as he did his cat and cold but
his captain called performance kept me
riveted I was just like wow man that's
[ __ ] crazy like he picked away to
drop each line that just made you
anticipate the next hoping like oh [ __ ]
that was cool do it again oh [ __ ] do it
again I like that performance a lot yeah
he is hanging up his ice gun you don't
want to do it no more he is stepping
away apparently for real from the
Berlanti verse yeah but he's done that
before hasn't he
cold died and it was a sabbatical and I
found himself backpacking in Europe and
then decided to come back but I think he
now for real is hanging it up it's a
bummer do you think they'll kill the
character off or leave the door open for
him to come back if he ever wanted to
come back I mean they could do both you
know they could kill him off and the
door would still be open to come back it
was that science fiction that's true if
you can bring Spock back from the dead
you can bring anybody back from the dead
excellent point and they did that within
the next what movie yeah it's of all of
like half an hour before they're like
yeah we're not killing [ __ ] Spock
what are we had on our minds remember
that [ __ ] when they found him on the on
the planet is breaking down the Genesis
planet and lieutenants Avex like he's
going through [ __ ] puberty because he
was going through Vulcan puberty he was
a [ __ ] every day yeah he won't leave
because he wants to keep coming in a
sock he's trying to watch a dirty movie
through squiggly lines on cable TV
it's called pon farr
oh it's called trick man old trick it's
coming now calm all right so wait we
were talking about what that got us to
Star Trek death of a character death of
Leonard snart whether or not it's for
real whether or not to last it's a
bummer man
I would like I like that day's
performance as a shame not to see him
doing it anymore but there's a pleasure
to watch him do it for as long as it did
but I still say last 10 years the team
is where the most interesting
performances I've ever seen I was like
wow that's not like that's better than
this show deserves but it's shocking
came out of nowhere and I didn't know
who the dude was and then made me
interested in the dude but not enough to
watch Prison Break that's it
that seems like that showed me over
after they break out of prison I don't
know how they kept [ __ ] going for
seasons season 3 break-in I guess that's
how all right what do we got next that
is about it from the from the old hit
list I'd sit on the mostly news front
and the mostly news right most of the
news is fun to talk about chitchat about
something tells me the next news piece
gonna be a little bit more somber yeah
all right let's have something in our
back pocket to go to afterwards though
to pivot so at least we can have a good
time
Q&A of course will follow but then you
know you know it's gonna take a minute
to forget the mics out what the first
question sucks
so let's no fans but you know so glad to
work think about it it's a good idea oh
[ __ ] well done all right all right
all right here we go
the next news story ladies gentlemen
sucks and it sucks to have to do because
we are we know people involved in the
news story and unfortunately these there
are a lot of these news stories lately
and for a minute I started to be like
well [ __ ] it must be me because I I know
too many people who've been called out
in these stories and then I get I don't
know who it was I think my wife was just
like this
problem is everybody knows these people
like you're not the only one there it's
all connected and it's all come now so
before we dive into that news story
there is a play a threat deacons here
tonight ladies and gentlemen a good
friend and a good friend of the show and
Brett works for this company for DX
which makes some of the finest [ __ ]
entertainment exhibition on the planet
I've talked about on the show before I
saw Captain America Civil War in a 40x
theater and a 40x chair-like and the
theater itself replicates the experience
in the movie so when it's snowing in the
movie it's snowing in the theater when
you know a [ __ ] motorcycle goes
ripping across screen that smell of
burnt rubber comes out of the seat you
get missed it if it's raining your chair
moves and shakes and [ __ ] it's like it's
like going on a ride while watching a
movie it's it's fantastic so they've got
a few theaters across the country
they've got one in New York they got one
Chicago and they got one here in Los
Angeles where is a deacon down at LA
live at LA live so Deacon brought how
many tickets ten tickets to the 40x
theater man and it's these are tickets
they're worth something because it's
pricey to see a movie in it but I I'm
not I have no connection to the place
other than I just enjoy their [ __ ]
work so much like they found a way to
make something I love and just watching
a movie even [ __ ] better like they
just take it to another level whatever
so tonight when we do our Q&A we got 10
tickets we'll do five questions for QA
and everyone who asks a question gets to
walk away with two tickets a pop man
thanks to deacon and the folks at 4dx so
that
that will be a fun thing to do now let's
do the not so fun stuff
go ahead last week two stories broke
revolving around the DC Universe one of
them in television one of them at comics
let's see eighty Braganza who was a
group editor at DC Comics was dismissed
for sexual misconduct that had sort of
emerged after a BuzzFeed article with
four or five women who came forward
named names and told their stories and
it seems that those events have been
going on ten years ago or so for about
three or four years he had been
reprimanded by the company he had been
demoted by the company he'd have been
promoted by the company he was moved
from New York to LA by the company it
seems as if those allegations were by
and large listened to and then ignored
and then many of those women who both
came forward in the BuzzFeed article and
some who didn't have found their way out
of both DC Comics and comics in general
because that experience soured them so
much on this thing that we all love and
it's it's it's always a shitty [ __ ]
story when you hear about stuff like
that it's it's oddly doubly shitty for
me because I have known ad brands for
twenty years we worked at Starlog
magazine together he was the first
person I knew who worked in comics and I
thought that that was where I was going
to go like everybody worked at Starlog
then went to work at DC except for me I
went to Entertainment Weekly maybe I'm a
journalist and not a comic book editor
but he called me and offered me static
shock when that opportunity came around
for me he I'm not gonna say he was a
friend friend but we were friendly for
certain hmm and then once and it feels
as if the dudes and comics are either
accidentally or sometimes willingly deaf
to the the rumors that you're here in
the industry about people like that but
once I did hear I severed all ties from
him like I own friended him I scrubbed
his email and all all that [ __ ] but it's
it is it is a weird thing to know
somebody who did reprehensible things
who is being punished for it absolutely
and
feels as if there should not be statute
of limitations for this kind of activity
you know and it's it's it is just a
weird [ __ ] thing to have to reckon
with to have known somebody for that
long and not known that this was who
they were you know and to try and and
both hold him accountable for his
actions and for his conduct but still
remember that there's a human being
there who probably has the potential and
capacity to evolve I'd like to think
that everybody can change that everybody
can learn from mistakes and become a
better person over time but you've got
to stare that thing in the face and deal
with it and I think that right now is
his moment of staring in the face and
dealing with it and I don't know who
will be on the other side of it and I
hope that he's got people near him that
will keep him from doing awful things to
himself because here's a dude who yes
did [ __ ] shitty things but also found
out this week that he doesn't have a
career anymore and I can see despair
grabbing hold of that really quickly so
I just hope that he doesn't do dumb [ __ ]
but I hope that he absolutely remembers
and reckons with his actions and his the
damage that he's caused you know the
collateral damage that that these people
might they don't understand going into
it how many people that's going to
affect but it's cascading and all of its
horrible and all of its bad and you know
and then Andrew Kreisberg the the
showrunner of Supergirl and executives
of the flash was accused by 19 women of
and a couple of dudes of sexual
misconduct of touching inappropriately
of comments that absolutely make it an
incredibly inhospitable workplace to say
the least if not outright threatening
and and so much of this is about the
abuse of power you know it's it's if you
were somebody's boss then they should
not be afraid of you they should not be
nobody should be afraid of anybody but
you have to realize that people are
unafraid to speak up for fear of their
careers Revere their potential for fear
of the
of livelihood and the Andrew Kreisberg
has denied flatly denied be mentally
denied according to the variety article
every accusation because the the variety
reporter Maureen Ryan had been working
on this story for months and she's got
nineteen different sources all of which
explained what happened to them and then
before they ran the article because
she's a real journalist they called
Andrew Kreisberg and said we're running
this tomorrow this is my guess
do you want to respond and his responses
were not how I remember it never
happened didn't do that never touched
her never touched him that's not what I
said
and if the if the beginning of healing
both yourself and the community has to
begin with staring yourself and your
actions in the mirror he doesn't seem to
be there yet as a result though andrew
has been suspended
yeah suspended pending review all right
QA let's Q&A it JC you got a microphone
ready to go take us fun places kids fun
places that feel clean and we'll give
you tickets to the most amazing
exhibition of a movie you've ever seen
in your life and what movies are coming
out that you can go see in 40 X you can
see Thor right now you can see last Jedi
coming up you can see Justice League
next week so I'm gonna set these up man
meanwhile who's going first you want to
pick them you pick them I'll pick him
yeah
all right let's come bad hat right here
yeah on the other side of the groom
groom Great Lord there there okay we all
know you're hoping for Green Lantern
Kevin yes but besides Green Lantern
who's the next guy you want on that team
is it Hawkman do you want Adam do you
want Green Arrow
who's next martian manhunter oh now
there was a moment back in the day when
was his name David the writer you know
who wrote Batman V Superman gory Oh gory
ER was on a podcast and like I'd never
do the Martian Manhunter that shit's
stupid but they do the Martian manner so
well on [ __ ] Supergirl time and time
again and Mark had a [ __ ] awesome
idea I mean he wasn't pitching but we
were just talking some [ __ ] about Wonder
Woman - they said Wonder Woman to Chris
Pine is coming back and we're
out of [ __ ] do you do that because
spoilers Steve Trevor [ __ ] died did
he not like give it his life he was a
hero so I was like is it the son of him
and does he just [ __ ] look like him
but if he's a son that means there was a
wife and did he cheat on the why it was
too much [ __ ] questions but mark goes
what if it's somebody who looks exactly
like Steve Trevor who turns out to be
the Martian Manhunter and that's when I
was like you should run Warner Brothers
man it's such a good [ __ ] idea a way
to get the Martian Manhunter into the
universe and stuff so I hope they go as
Jon Jones I hope they eventually bring
them into the justices yeah you win the
tickets there you go and you're going to
see a 40 X movie my friend JC take us
elsewhere no there's no [ __ ] I know
but Tyco YTD he's talented
the Jeph Loeb once said you go or was it
joke us out you know what I spoke with
Jeff love about working on the shows but
it was Joe Quezada Joe Quezada who
technically you know is a pro sir on all
those Marvel Network shows he came over
do podcast couple times house one of the
other time last times he came over and
not last time because those are get out
but just one of the most recent times he
was there I said I want to get on one of
them I want to do an episode of [ __ ]
daredevil he goes not as long as you're
making flash and I said are you serious
man he goes DC or marvel
so I thought that was adorable I was
like all right well I'm [ __ ] up but or
maybe it's this nice way of saying we
don't want the guy who did tusks getting
anywhere near all this [ __ ] wonderful
[ __ ] we're on a hit streak iron fist
notwithstanding we don't want any
[ __ ] help from you but yeah he said
that because I was doing I I mean I
don't know it'd be nice on some level to
go direct an episode of daredevil just
because I'd been involved with the
character in comics same way it'd be a
cool to go do an episode of arrow
because I was involved with the
character in comics but the rest of the
Netflix shows I don't watch them and
going oh my god I want to do that or
something happy to be a fan and just
enjoy that [ __ ] but the daredevil
connectivity based on having to worked
on the character like 20 years ago with
Joe you know is there's something there
where I'm like who I would do that but
honestly those shows are shot insanely
well and directed really well that
hallway fight in episode 2 season 1 I
couldn't [ __ ] do something like that
if somebody handed me that script I'd be
like a higher director you know like
that's what you are Mike no I just
really buy food for the crew a more of a
genial host to than anything else all
right we good you get [ __ ] two
tickets to go see a 40 X movie my friend
where we going next to see all the way
in the back thank you so I'm not trying
to get extra tickets but I'm also trying
to settle a debate between my sister
toilet paper over or under over oh thank
you sir thank you sister do under yes
the [ __ ] is wrong with your system
that's where you Maxine but no so let's
assume that Disney a Australian
government no holy I was trying to
figure out my hand if I'm wiping if I'm
a guy wiping I'm sitting down to wipe I
pull off the toilet paper most guys I
imagine leaned forward but I'm a tuck
and go for back kind of guy so they go
back there and I kind of tuck through
here but I imagine if I'm a normal guy I
pull it off I go back here if I'm a lady
you pulling this way and then going this
way so it's a swift motion which we've
right that's part one the fantasy world
where Disney does by not just x-men and
Fantastic Four a spider-man of course
they don't I remember but also The
Simpsons and show like that every the
whole universe yes so what fought but
Fox doesn't own that right so they would
get star wars under one roof boy this
[ __ ] Disney cell would solve a lot of
loose strings and problems Kevin Feige
just sitting on the sidelines going do
it do it like 90 spider-man a cartoon
series he was kind of suave debonair
he would come in and I could see him
being you know a good guy
so cut the cords what characters do you
see that could mingle within other
characters to make their stories even
better to make that show or that movie
you know just to the next level because
you don't have any red tape who do you
want to introduce do you want to you
know and not something so obvious as you
know everybody's to be rooting for x-men
Avengers because obviously but something
like you know what these two characters
and and please both of you answer
these two characters would really
introduce on the next level to this
story hmm you go
I would part of me it's like I want to
see this Savage Land in Planet of the
Apes commingle because you could do that
but I want I want Mulder and Scully to
have to investigate an ex crime and
thought of that Disney would own the
x-files yeah Wow like Disney would have
so much they would triple their IP
that's crazy man
even [ __ ] Scully and Mulder like we
own that too we own that I'm knocking on
the door on Graymalkin Lane being like
there's a we got a crime here with a
mutant they show up in ya Xavier Mansion
yeah that's cool
I like that I like yours I don't have
one
I was thinking well if they get
everything back all right here you go
all right all right the creative juices
are flowing bring it if Disney were to
buy all the Fox properties and
everything is one Disney under one
Disney umbrella
the Fantastic Four verse The Incredibles
you didn't know how much you wanted that
movie until I just pitched it
[ __ ] man the movie that did the
Fantastic Four most right fighting the
Fantastic Four
that's fantastic you get what's name to
direct it
Brad Brad bird and it's it's all Pixar
it's all CG you let the fans out there
that's your way out of that [ __ ]
Fantastic Four hole where everyone's
like they can't get it right just
[ __ ] do it as a Pixar cartoon with
The Incredibles for every dumbass who
can't figure out that The Incredibles
literally is Fantastic Four you put them
in the same movie and people like oh now
we like it that's my pitch I feel pretty
good about that nice job thank you I
like you you won some tickets give it up
for armies going on 40 X movie where to
next JC
as the mic goes around around there's
only two sets of tickets left two
questions left here we go
how'd you do how did you feel about the
New Mutants trailer the [ __ ] mutants
with x-men and everything we talked
about it last week so the last show we
were here right did we I don't know if
that's ticket worthy yeah that may not
be ticket where they live but we could
still answer the question I thought it
was [ __ ] fantastic you know I like
that kid who directed the first boom yes
he directed Fault in Our Stars he came
over to the podcast those lovely [ __ ]
dude and [ __ ] he had plans for another
flick I think he wanted to do the stand
didn't [ __ ] quite work out it was it
was very ambitious so when I heard he
got this I was like oh good for him man
cuz he also at one point had a pitch for
a spider-man movie if I remember
correctly pretty good pitch for it too
he told me about very 70 spider-man so
when I heard he got the job I was like
oh great and New Mutants alright that's
[ __ ] cool it's the next movie but
whatever but that trailer is
spellbinding like it's better than any
version of the New Mutants that I had in
my head and the fact that it's a Fox
movie the fact that they're sitting
there gone like oK we've redefined the
comic book movie with Deadpool we've
redefined it again with Logan it feels
like they're also redefining it with New
Mutants a little bit if if the movie
holds to as powerful as that trailer is
it's an interesting idea to be like your
mutant powers are horrific that's kind
of cool so I'm all for it you yeah I
mean what you said all right where are
we going next where we're going next
Moose Jaw stands very well if you've got
some money to make it moose jaw's are
surprisingly tough movie to finance a
movie about jaws with if it had been a
moose instead of a shark it's easier to
get Jay and Silent Bob reboot financed
that's what we're doing next and I think
hopefully February we start the open the
offices and stuff but
so hopefully that works and then we get
to move on to moose jaw's but right now
moose jaw's goes by the wayside while
something else goes first mall rat
series nobody picked up we talked about
that a while ago you don't get tickets
for that depressing ass [ __ ] yeah
for what no but that's also old news too
and also part of the rules is like he
got to ask us both it can't be like ya
can't leave a mark out we got two rounds
of tickets man you grab the tickets
going here we go to questions but fair
enough fair enough that works so I'm
kind of wondering cuz chasing you is one
my favorite movies of all time are you
leaving mark barnard and out of this
question I am NOT in fact the hoop so
but black people in it so your next
pirate part too so anyway so question
number one which is only for you how did
you get Joey Lawrence to essentially
play herself in the movie because she
said many times chasing amy as she was
reading it felt like an ongoing apology
she was like it was argue
that we'd had and like it was almost in
writing the scenes like you know he was
saying oh I understand I'm an [ __ ] or
something like that so she was into the
idea and plus you know she wanted to do
a meaty part like she was the girl that
didn't get a lot of parts because they
were like all your [ __ ] voice or
something like that and like her most
well-known most well-known role was she
took bud Bundy's virginity so you know
nobody was like here's a fat script with
tons of dialogue where you get to
express yourself at the same time most
actors or actresses handed a script
they're getting to play somebody
completely different not only was she
getting a party part but it was also
therapeutic at the same time as she went
on to in the movie essentially win every
argument and stuff and essentially find
me going like oh I was wrong I should
have grown up blah blah blah jaesi game
it was very therapeutic for me I grew up
by the end of that movie but she's
already advanced beyond me so I grew up
it was too late the relationship fell
apart so is bittersweet and whatnot and
I think the chief reason she did it was
because it's a big it was a big part
nobody else was being like here's a lead
in a movie you're the female lead so why
wouldn't she do it and the fact that it
was about our relationship she liked
although she was prophetic about it as I
was writing it she's like this will
probably end our relationship and I was
like are you kidding me this'll only
bring us closer together and we were
both right it was just the timing was
dim the relationship ya know we were
dating like when the movie came out we
did so much press together I remember is
[ __ ] crazy we did like some Vogue
piece or something like that and so you
know when they do that like the give the
women like tons outfits and [ __ ] and you
know generally now I wear one outfit I'm
like I'm fine I'll wear what I [ __ ]
wear but back then you know I was like
they were like we brought a stylist and
I was like what's that and and they gave
me clothes to wear and [ __ ] and then
they had a dude's like do my hair so
there's a picture of me and Joey Adams
that like I look I look like a 90's boy
band version of myself
so yeah we did press together on the
movie it was just as the movie was like
coming we went the movie came broke in
January of 97 at Sundance and then came
out in April of 97 and then by July of
97 we were kind of done goes for Mark
all right considering the fact that you
know your career started basically doing
nothing but like personal movies where
you were just you know putting yourself
as an avatar and your comic-book career
basically started with you putting
yourself you know like like all your
frustrations this team they were coming
on comments at least is from what you
I've been listening to for a few years
of having Batman but you've both been
kind of getting away from that you know
you with like you know just you know
sillier movies and you with like you
know kind of more sci-fi horror why do
you think your career has gone that way
and do you think you'll be going back to
more personal things well I get paid
more but I'll say this like there's
there's no way if you're if you're a
storyteller and if you have lived a life
and you believe in the stories you're
telling there's no way to divorce
yourself entirely from the work there's
always going to be a part of you in what
you're right you always going to bring
the things that are uniquely you to
whatever you're doing and so even if I'm
writing on a show like Castle Rock even
from writing creator-owned book you're
writing a work-for-hire thing whatever
that is there's always going to be a
piece of me in it and the work suffers
when there isn't and I think that
anybody who's employed me kind of
realizes that you know even when I'm a
journalist and I'm supposed to be
objective you still bring a perspective
to the news you can still decide to
cover things because they interest you
because you believe in it even if you're
covering them without bias you know what
I mean like did you you walk through the
world unlike anybody else and it would
be a shame if
didn't take advantage of the fact that
you are different from everybody else
and help other people see that that
difference is not a bad thing that
difference only adds you know it's the
you know America is not a melting pot
it's a mosaic you know you're not you
know blending and melting everything
into one sludge you're keeping the
awesome colored shards of every single
person and together we make a big
picture even if right now the light
seems to be a little bit off that
picture but that was deep and long well
done well done I feel an early word
[ __ ] I learned at the feet of the
master I I'm done yeah you read that was
you too my crop will I get back to more
personal stuff I don't know it feels
like that's where I do the personal
stuff in the podcasts a lot I feel like
you know back when I was making just
movies there was a lot less place to put
the content there was the movie so you
know [ __ ] chasing amy was like all
right let me [ __ ] deal with my issues
and and write a movie at the same time
but I get to deal with my issues on like
six different podcasts every week and it
come and I got to fill those podcasts so
that content goes there and yeah there's
some times you know where people like oh
you shouldn't have said that on a
podcast you could totally do that as a
movie but I'm like I did that once and
twice it really didn't [ __ ] work out
so generally speaking I don't that's
where I kind of do my best personal
stuff like I like those movies I love
those movies don't get me wrong but they
don't tell the story of my life
like the podcasts do and that's all
those movies were meant to be for me for
everybody else there you know [ __ ]
entertainment [ __ ] but that's just the
story of my life like clerks was a story
of my life Mallrats is the story of my
life chasing amy was the story of my
life
Dogma - the rubber poop monster was kind
of the story of my life that's where
things started to get off the rails and
fantastical Jersey girl was the story of
my life stripped right out of my life
and stuff although my wife was like it
ain't your real life because your wife
didn't [ __ ] die
she when she first read the script she
guy was like what do you think I said I
wrote this as a valentine to you and she
goes the [ __ ] mother of the girl dies
in the first half hour and then you
[ __ ] remarry Liv Tyler how is this
about me all right you get some tickets
give him some [ __ ] tickets checking
and then we got one set a 40 X ticket
and a deer's lady you should get a lady
asking a question yeah yeah all right
you want 40 X tickets you want to ask a
question cat ears is gonna join us again
and ask a question hopefully we'll see
we'll see if we can answer based on our
nd I think Patrick Stewart at least
deserves a nomination and a word and
mark you had said that you thought
October maybe do you still have those
feelings and do you think it has any
chance of being nominated still I
watched it again recently as well and
[ __ ] does it hold up and it's a
masterfully made film and you're right
Patrick Stewart could totally [ __ ]
rock a Best Supporting Actor nomination
particularly because it's a poignant
performance and probably the best
rendition of a character that he's
played multiple times and this is
probably the last time he's gonna play
that character why not [ __ ] give him
a nod man I thought he was tremendous
and the movie really [ __ ] works like
crazy it's beautiful like you know
spoilers when that [ __ ] cross she
turns it onto its side as an axe oh you
just instantly you like hit the [ __ ] out
of here how did I never see that I've
been going to Catholic Church my whole
life all I had to do was tilt the
[ __ ] cross like
comments so uh I hope I don't see why
that movie can't get a few nominations
like I I have my feelings I don't have
less to do with the quality of the movie
and I love Logan to death more about the
politics more about the politics of
campaigning for awards and and the sort
of short term memory of most Academy
voters and a thing that comes out in
February
all too often like it's already on video
it's already had its life it's not it's
not in the zeitgeist the way that it the
movies that are coming out in November
December will be that said there doesn't
seem to be an overwhelming amount of
Oscar contenders this year you know like
so far it seems a little anemic and kind
of thing and also Deadpool had its award
run did and not that Oscar run but
didn't get a Golden Globe or something
that came out in February yeah I mean
there's there's a chance for it it's a
it's a slim chance but it's absolutely
there and if there's not a lot of
competition then there's a world in
which the love for Patrick Stewart and
the respect for that movie sort of
carries the day for it but I hope it
does because god I love that [ __ ] I
think that requires I think there are a
few roles that are going to require fan
fandom driven campaigns to make an
impact one is Michael Rooker and
Guardians 2 like that performance
deserves why not him and Patrick Stewart
in Logan those are two examples coming
from two comic book quote-unquote comic
book movies that you know it's not even
they transcend the medium because I love
the medium but that should be enough for
an awards person to be like came in
[ __ ] I'll give a [ __ ] if it's about
mutants or if it's about you know Batman
or whatever [ __ ] like I'm gonna give
this a not they did it once before for
Heath Ledger and the Dark Knight and
then you know some people point out like
Suicide Squad want a makeup award we're
not talking about that [ __ ] we're
talking about
good for them but we're talking about
the biggies man we want a big award for
those like you can never tell how
[ __ ] we are the campaign for awards
is gonna be like get out universals
decided to get out will now compete in
for the Golden Globes in the Comedy
category well I mean well it's what you
think it should be drama
I mean it's there's nothing funny about
get out yeah I guess you're right it's
more satiric and clever yeah like it's
it's but there was nothing funny about
the Martian they won they won the Comedy
Award they did I mean there's a joke or
two in the Martian and I don't remember
a joke or two and get out it was a joke
or two but I mean that's a thriller
that's an out-and-out drama if ever
there was one but I think they just feel
like they've got a better shot at
winning a Golden Globe I'm making a
comedy which feels [ __ ] weird but
okay whatever like that's how arbitrary
and ridiculous Awards campaigning is but
the Martian yeah we just were talking
about the the the what was what how
about last year did a Deadpool got
Golden Globe but did anything comic book
Orientalism Mako was anything else even
or anything I don't think so I mean the
year before was the was the fury road
year oh that's right and that was kind
of genres totally and they're pushing
Wonder Woman hard like I got I got my
Wonder Woman screener real Awards yeah
what are they what do you think I mean
they always like it in case you don't
know whenever they send out these outs
for screeners it says for your
consideration in all categories right so
it's Best Picture Best Director Best
Screenplay do you think they're glad for
though what are the best chances let's
put it at that I mean I think they're
going for an actress which is a long
shot but I are we still doing 10 Best
Picture nominations yeah I bet you this
I bet you they can swing for and hit a
nomination for Wonder Woman that movie
was so [ __ ] beloved made so much
[ __ ] money why not like yeah you
gotta you got to put 10 titles up only 5
of them are really competing really
let's be honest only three will be
competing at the end of the day so you
got 7 other spots to fill why not give
it to the movie that was cultural
breakthrough and box-office breakthrough
and
yeah it'll be it'll be that thing the
here's the movie that everybody [ __ ]
saw so now we get people to watch the
Oscars because who's a movie that
everybody saw that they're invested in I
don't think it has a chance I think
you're right but if I get a nomination
that would be huge yeah yeah nomination
for Patrick Stewart I totally get behind
I could get Ben and might and Michael
Rooker I get behind that there any other
big comic book performances I mean look
I love the Hemsworth and Thor but I'm
not like give my Oscar we got to keep
our standards but I haven't seen justice
league yet maybe there's something in
there I would for the record hey hey hey
wait go ahead Oh God say for the record
the shade on justice league is coming
from you and not from me I want to see
in a big bad way I'm in the bag for it I
can't wait here's what we're forgetting
about for Oscar season well Mark Hamill
playing Luke Skywalker even even I don't
think this is possible because the man's
insanely gifted even if he [ __ ] it all
up to Sunday drop the ball and it was
like I woke like where you were like
this ain't what I [ __ ] remember even
if he did that he has to [ __ ] get a
nomination and I mean I don't he looks
like a lead but you could definitely get
him a Best Supporting nod right yeah why
am I talking to you you didn't see it
like up cat ears you think it you think
I think so there's no way he doesn't get
some sort of nod I think there's there's
definitely the room there's always a
slot for the career appreciation which
means that I bet you carry probably gets
a nomination as well for Best Supporting
Actress
yeah she what happened she had a lot
more screen time they said in this one
they said the real tragedy was all of
her screen time was in the last one to
come but they said she's got some meaty
screen time I mean come on man like how
many minutes do you have to even be in a
movie to get it nominated was it the
late Judi Dench was nominated in one for
16 minutes of Shakespeare in Love she
was amazing and Shakespearean was
awesome but it's like so it's it's a
commercial break she was in that movie
for it it's true signs the lamps what
whoo yeah but he was in the whole
[ __ ] movie wasn't here he's only in
that movie for 10 minutes are you
[ __ ] serious Silence of the Lambs not
like [ __ ] red dragon or any of that
[ __ ] Silence of the Lambs if you put all
the Hannibal Lecter scenes together it's
only ten minutes that is [ __ ] insane
what do you say roughly is that like 10
minutes or 40 roughly is it really I
don't know the most important piece of
information I've learned in a month
that's useful information like that's a
that [ __ ] mind blower man I'm gonna
totally go home tell my wife how long
you think Anthony Hawkins it's it's
those of the Lambs that's all the time
we got for this lead evening ladies and
gentleman have you had a good time this
evening
we cannot thank you enough for coming
out we love doing the show here we love
doing the show period we love doing the
show here at scum and villainy we love
doing it interactively with a crowd and
audience and stuff like that and we love
doing it with y'all thanks for giving us
something [ __ ] fun to do on this
Tuesday Thursday on a Tuesday night man
for fat man I'm Batman I've been Kevin
Smith and I'm mark barnard tune in next
time same bat-time same bat-channel
smart guest doc I'm more youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you